my mom is you know she's Filipino yeah
you know and she never wanted me to be a
comic you know she wanted me she wanted
you to be she wanted me to be in the
b-boy at the hospital no not a b-boy
either doctor she wanted if you have
talent you know it's only until high
school ends yeah yeah yeah and then the
talent must stop now you need a career
now it's a hobby now you yeah that's
stop it
dancing so it's like you know what are
you a clown like
what the [ __ ] yeah and then so yeah so
she wanted me to be but imagine like I
also like have a lot of empathy for
those parents because it's like imagine
you risk everything to come to America
bust your [ __ ] ass there you go and
then your kid wants to be a dancer
exactly yeah yeah like I'm so happy you
said it but like better it sounds better
when you say it yeah
[Applause]
I knew I could trust you no but I'm glad
you said that because not everyone gets
I I feel for them you'll get it but
people that that aren't Filipino don't
get it dude they just see oh you made it
to America now to shut up yeah you made
it yeah you're good you don't know that
my mom left her entire family yeah she
literally like she might not see them
for years he didn't see him yeah she
knew it and now I'm just gonna provide a
better life for my kids and also
whatever leftover money I'm gonna make
I'm gonna send it back to them yeah so
that they have a better future yeah but
people in America don't see them you
want to dance I want to dance
fat laces
yeah I said I already have shoelaces
what you think of what they gave up for
stability and security and then you're
saying [ __ ] all that's why Asians always
want their kids to be doctors agents I'm
including myself in because doctors
security yeah yeah yeah we don't believe
yeah we don't do that oh you don't do
that here okay what kind of race
how are you oppressing this guy he's
Latino he's Latino okay I don't care
unless there's a gift
[Laughter]
them's the rules no but they they're
it's I gave up everything all my
security to make your life secure so
enter the most secure fecal possible be
a doctor people will always be sick
that's why it's the dream because this
is what I came here for I gave up
everything for me so you could be secure
and now you're gonna go have a dream you
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] you I had the dream
yeah I got us here yeah we're done yes
whites are a little bit like uh how do I
say it my mom my mom immigrated here
right so like I I relate to this but
like most white people in America are a
few Generations away from the parent
that left the Homeland yeah but America
is a bunch of people who did what your
mom did yeah so like in our core we
relate to it yes in our core everybody
had a family member who just left it all
behind yeah came here probably didn't
see their family that much yeah and it
came from maybe like a tricky
circumstance yeah and I think that white
people are kind of maybe a few
Generations removed from it yeah so
maybe they don't they don't get it but
if you ask like a white dude's
grandparent how they would feel about
your mom's situation they'd be like I
was so pissed off when your mom wanted
to be a [ __ ] ballerina yeah do you
know what I mean like they would also
probably feel I hear you yeah there's a
there's a risk taker niss in our DNA
here in America yeah yeah so not all of
us but yeah
always
with people they always like bring up
this trauma you know
that story is a little too specific to
tell right now you guys you guys but you
do feel the same as black people mostly
but my mom's experience was so similar
he took a plane they love dancing
when she works but here's the difference
when your mom wanted to be a ballerina
yeah Ballroom ballroom dancing he only
looked at the white dancers you know
what not that dancer and not that even
though that's the best answer
he's just being funny
don't be freaked out and I was really
upset about that yes yes yes there was
less opportunities
um yeah but when did your mom come
around that was what I was curious about
she like I said she's she's old school I
don't know if you can relate but like it
doesn't matter Stephen Spielberg okay
well
what else are you going to do Joker
really well I mean now it's a little
better this is the show what about the
bank account like do you just show her
the Straight Cash you bought our house
I'm assuming yeah yeah you [ __ ] on some
of your like Medical Professional
friends a lot of cards I uh yeah you
know my mom got so comfortable she
bought a car no bro
what type what what types yeah uh types
but the last one I didn't even go pick
it she already went
already went to this is after the third
one right yeah already went to the place
already
purchased it I sent me a picture of it
oh and goes is uh can you just uh send
uh what what information do you need
what what information do you need like
is what I don't know
there's so many Sierra
enjoy driving
negotiation do you need
I told him Spielberg
[Applause]
Jesus Christ what type of car Mercedes
let's go mom yeah she got good taste
yeah that's awesome why did you tell her
to ask one of her doctor friends to pay
for it
I'm really impressed with how far you
come I'm really like I'm really just so
I'm Blown Away watching it but I want
you to know no matter how successful you
are I would still rather you be a doctor
I swear to God he said This I Swear yeah
yeah I swear they love titles by the way
life support
[Laughter]
yes I'm not a doctor
[Laughter]
that's so funny and I laughed and he
laughed and he was like I know it's
stupid but I'm an Indian father I can't
tell you any different it's who I am and
I wasn't even mad at it because it was
so like authentic yeah but it was such a
funny thing I'll never forget don't
relate to the doctor thing yeah that's
crazy yeah
it's so funny that's the titles that
they're addicted to yeah
they'll never call someone oh that's my
friend John that's Attorney John
yeah yeah dirty John and now your
comedian Joe that's Attorney John no no
I'm just oh that's Joseph
[Laughter]
but she saw you on Netflix though she
like oh wow oh yeah I mean
no she's older now and you know and my
stepdad is not doing too well and uh
yeah but uh
she's uh she's very proud I mean
everyone I don't know how to say it
everyone knows who I am in the
Philippines so it's like your mom to see
yeah you know she loves it she's like no
she loves where she everyone everyone
knows my mom
oh she's famous oh she's very over there
as well no she's she lives here and
she's she's big everyone knows her they
really yeah she does her interviews and
she does all that yeah
she called the napkins
I still remember from 2007 to joke about
her teaching you how to fight and
putting your keys in between the two
fingers and I was like yo Filipinas get
it dog you know what's crazy about that
joke is everyone walks up to me so
that's why I get like mad when you're
like you're not really listening she's
just being a mom well yeah so everyone
talks I have people coming up to me like
I do that same thing with the keys
nothing so so here's the thing the
Immigrant experience and I think that a
lot of comics who talk about it
especially with their parents being
immigrants have seen this like your
audience is not just Filipino you have
so many different people on your
audience yeah and you've also seen this
like with Sebastian a little bit as well
like the Immigrant experience for the
Italian father or the Filipino mother is
not that dissimilar no there's so much
that they're going through so then all
these people get to relate to it oh my
grandma did the exact same thing man
yeah yeah yeah 100 years I'll go to like
San Antonio there's no Filipinos in the
audience
they got a lot of keys yeah they got a
bootleg Tupperware yeah yeah
but sometimes you messed me up which
one's my camera
[Laughter]
that's why we should cancel
it
we're trying to cancel them and you sent
me to a stage light
um Joe we know hey I'm sorry I have to
ask one more question what was it like
performing for the in like in the
Philippines how was that different than
America because for me going back to
India is always a [ __ ] thing it's
very it was it was nuts that was nuts
did you feel what felt different within
you I used to live there I lived there
for six years all right [ __ ] so I I was
like from four to ten the most memorable
years of my life right and uh so like
just right right when you get off the
plane you smell something I remember I
looked at my son I go this just brought
me back to my childhood I smelt this
smell yeah that I smell and then uh and
then just being with my son was just so
yeah a moment you know right right then
it was a Wednesday uh it's a Wednesday
bro and I sold out an arena on a
Wednesday that's so crazy like it was
just amazing and everybody was there
there was
did you feel more pressure was the big
guy there Pacquiao was the big guy there
they were all there Annie no man he
wasn't there he uh but they were
there were people there I don't want to
say any names I don't need to do that
but yeah
but yeah there were people there but as
far as pressure no
I don't I that was the one message I was
trying to get across to on stage that
night is uh the whole that crab
mentality yeah and I just wanted to let
that be heard huh Josh that was one
thing I went on a rant for like 15
minutes you know we're so we're so quick
to just pull somebody down but not
understand the struggle it takes to get
to where we get to right or understand
what what they're trying to do you just
want to take it down yeah and then you
and then you wonder why the doors closed
right because every time it opens you
close it yeah yeah yeah so that's that
just help one another minute well that's
that scarcity mentality I think a lot of
times like I think that's where it comes
from is when you're I'm imagining right
I'm a [ __ ] white dude and this but
it's like well you're going well there's
only so many rules for Asians so you're
like well if he got it that means I'm
not gonna get it [ __ ] that guy yeah so
you develop this mentality which is like
you're really competing against
everybody else in your community for
that like one slot yeah and if there's a
bunch more slots all of a sudden you get
to support them a little bit more and
say hey that's awesome you got that
because there's some more over here and
that's the beauty of the internet right
yeah the internet is abundance we can
all have a [ __ ] podcast we can all
have a comedy special we can all have a
show we can have everything yeah and the
people that want to indulge in it get to
decide what they like the best yes so
hopefully that goes away no we don't say
hopefully it's going to go away it's
gonna go away